(upbeat music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show
the number one podcast for growing
and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell.
And we're from Think Media and if
this is your first time listening welcome,
- This show is dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content notice and
the latest money making strategies
working right now online.
So whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
How do you make money
with a small channel?
I'm excited about this 'cause I have
a small channel mine's only
at almost 15,000 subscribers.
And we have a lot of
people who look at you
with 1.5 million subscribers having
a seven figure media company,
all these big things,
but everything
starts small.
- Yeah.
So talk about how do you make
money with a small channel?
- Well, first of all actually think that
even your channel I
wouldn't consider small
I mean, 15,000 is insane, you know
and you've already made quite a
bit of money off of your channel.
And so I think that you know the question
with you what small maybe hard to say
maybe your first 1000 your first 5000
or up to 10,000 subscribers.
I think about friends of mine that were
able to go full time
around 10,000 subscribers.
I was able to go full time
at around 20,000 subscribers
I went all in on Think Media
at 16,000 full time at 20.
So what are the strategies?
Well, the first thing and I know that
this is going to be one of those like,
Okay, come on man like,
but the first thing
is actually like not to
focus on making money
at all first, but to focus on influence.
First, you know our phrase over at video
influencers helping you build
your influence, income and impact.
And we say it in that order,
because it actually is a progression.
That you can't make income if you don't
have influence and you
can't make a difference
and an impact if you don't have
influence or income in our opinion.
Because if you can't keep the lights on
or if you're starving yourself,
then how are you gonna
ultimately impact others?
You need money to fuel the mission.
So it all starts with influence.
And the reason I say that is
the first thing I would say,
to make money on a small channel
is find another way to make money.
Like too many people I think they
maybe start with desperation, which is
the worst way to start anything.
If you start in a
desperate place on YouTube,
you'll make bad decisions.
You might try to make quick
money with affiliate marketing.
We'll talk about that in a second.
And it can be good but too early,
and it's maybe coming
from the wrong place,
you might try to use gimmicks and
you might try to use clickbait,
as opposed to saying, you know what,
I'm going to identify
another way to make money
so that I can even fund my YouTube channel
in its infancy stage.
In my case, I actually started my channel
Clear Vision Media for
my company back in 2009.
And I had a freelance
video production company
and then I started Think Media in 2010.
So in 2009, I use my
cameras and my lighting
and all these things that I actually got
from taking a loan out and the way
I was paying the loan down was
from waiting tables at Red Robin.
And I thought if I can
make money in my business,
I can at least just make extra tips
on the weekends and eventually pay this
thing down and took out a
$7,000 loan to get the gear.
And I realized that I
was gonna pay the bills
via doing freelance video work
building websites, doing
YouTube optimization,
and then use YouTube to do YouTube
and affiliate marketing,
reviewing cameras,
with really no timeline of
when I needed that to succeed.
I think that's a good recipe.
Another way is like
work at some other job,
you know freelance online whether that's
doing virtual assistant work,
or doing graphic design
or using any skill,
doing a call center or just doing anything
so that way you can invest
in your YouTube channel
without needing to like make a
demand on your audience too soon.
- Yeah, I think that's
really, really important.
I've found that with even
my homeschool channel,
I work for Think Media and so I have
zero pressure on that
end to fund that mission.
But it is a mission like
it's close to my heart,
but I don't have the
time to make courses yet.
I don't have the time to
develop the curriculum
that I want to I don't have that time yet.
So one of the things you introduced to me
was this idea of affiliate marketing.
And I know that's how you went full time.
So let's talk about what it is and how you
can apply that to your YouTube channel as
a small channel to start making money.
- Yeah, you know that
also, affiliate marketing
requires a little bit of influence.
Because we talk about affiliate marketing,
we recommend signing up for
the Amazon Associates Program,
because Amazon is the everything store
and pretty much everything is there,
when you sign up and
you get a custom link.
Now, when someone clicks
your link and buy something,
you'll make between four
and 10% off that sale.
And this is a way that
initially I was able
to quit my day job and go full time
on YouTube was just
through Amazon and YouTube
and talking about tech and cameras
on my channel Think Media.
However, early on people
go that sounds awesome.
So they try to apply for the
Amazon Associate Program.
They have one or two videos up.
They only have 33
subscribers or maybe they
even have 3000 subscribers the
average video gets around 350 views,
but you don't have a ton of momentum yet
a ton of influence yet.
And so what people do is they apply
for an affiliate program, they either
don't get approved or they get approved,
but they don't make enough sales
within enough amount of time.
So then their account gets shut down.
It goes back to needing influence first
needing to kind of hit a tipping point
of growth a tipping point of kind
of breaking through with your content.
And so once you hit what
I'd probably recommend
is that you probably want
at least 10 to 20 videos.
And it would be ideal to probably have
at least 500 to 1000
subscribers around there
in with some level of consistency
not 1000 to 5000
subscribers, let's say that
you built over five years and they
just slowly grew on there.
But just like you did you started knowing
you were gonna do homeschool.
You started with homeschool topic videos,
you started to build momentum.
Of course also ranking videos answering
specific questions being a video
ranking academy student just doing
that like to the tee and it really worked
'cause your channels growing on autopilot
even if you don't upload a lot of videos.
And then it was no friction for you
to get approved for the
Amazon affiliate program
to work with other affiliate programs
through curriculum companies.
So yeah, affiliate marketing
is what I would recommend.
And notice we didn't say
YouTube ads in any other way.
I think affiliate
marketing is the best way
to start making money as a small channel,
because you don't need
a brand to select you
for a brand deal or waste
your time emailing brands
when you're super small and
it's just a ton of work.
You can as soon as you get
approved for that program,
you can start making money
based on your results.
If you can figure out just and all
you need is one video to
really change your life.
We've mentioned the greens powder video
where I have a green
juice powder that I mix up
that video is earned over
$10,000 it's one video
in one niche around one
keyword that blew up
like that I've got this video called
best Christmas LED lights.
One video that video is
generated over $10,000
and every year generates more.
One video around one keyword in one niche.
I didn't get the brand to work with me,
I didn't get free products sent to me
I actually purchased the product myself,
or actually I was I got to
borrow it from a friend.
But I hustled to get it.
- Yeah.
Like I didn't have to
talk to anybody else.
I was empowered myself to
use affiliate marketing.
I know, maybe this is some
new terms to some people.
So we actually have a playlist over on
Think Media, our affiliate
marketing series,
we go deep, and so people can learn
a little bit more about
affiliate marketing,
as I think the best way to make money
with a small channel when
you're getting started.
- Yeah, and a lot of
times, one of the mistakes
we see is that people will just put links
down below and there's
no reference point to it.
So talk about how you were able
to go full time with affiliate marketing,
because of the connection or tell
us a little bit more about that.
- I think yeah and we
actually teach that in
a program and maybe we'll just link to it
because it's a baby course.
- Yeah.
That have called Video
Product Review Profits,
and I'll just put a link to
that in the description below.
And I talked about, I
think five unique things
you need to know about making money
with affiliate marketing
through product reviews.
That's where people make a mistake.
They just have like a vlogging channel
and they think I'm gonna
vlog I'll link up to
the camera using the description and then
some people will click
that I'll make money.
No, because the intent in
watching your entertaining vlog
is not to then check out the description
for things to like buy and
they're not looking for a camera.
Conversely, if you do a video called
Blendtec versus Ninja Blenders,
which one is better?
The person who's watching
a video like that
probably wants to buy a blender at
the end of that viewing session.
So what I mean is and what
we teach in that program
is being congruent
through the whole process.
Really thinking through
what is the online consumer,
the online shopper which by the way,
that's why I love affiliate marketing.
E-commerce is only around 15% going
into 2020 and this next decade,
like that means that I mean again,
only 15 out of 100 people
are shopping online,
most people are still shopping offline.
Well that's going to
continue to grow more people
are gonna keep shopping online.
That means more opportunity for us
to do product reviews to
cover products we love
and use and do product tutorials to make
a lot of money through
affiliate marketing.
So when what's the intent of
the consumer who comes online?
What are they searching for?
And then when they watch the video,
what kind of information
do they want to learn?
And then what do they need to know
about doing next helping them make
that next decision to click on that link.
And then even thinking past that click
to the fact that you say
this product is amazing.
But then they get to the page and
the page is not super optimized,
or there's horrible you say it's amazing,
but there's horrible reviews on Amazon,
no one's gonna buy that because you
also then your credibility
is lost in that.
So you're thinking through a whole what
we would call like a customer journey,
which is a whole different approach than
most people when it comes
to affiliate marketing.
They just kinda lob it out there.
Hope to get some clicks,
hope to get some sales.
And I've learned that you know,
just hope marketing doesn't work.
- Yeah.
- You have to do strategic marketing.
And again, we'll link to some resources
that people are interested in.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets to
our annual conference Grow With
Video Live a 1500 dollar value,
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple podcast,
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
- Yeah okay, so build influence first,
start with affiliate marketing.
And then our third point
is to sell something.
- Yes you know, like, we didn't even
mention YouTube ads.
- Yeah.
And you know what's cool about YouTube
is that if you get
approved for monetization
after 1000 subscribers400 hours,
4000 hours of watch time,
within 12 months period,
now you can monetize your videos.
Sometimes people get so myopic,
so focused on just that
way of making money
and it's a losing recipe because
what I've learned is even
if you start getting,
you know 500,000 views a month, depending
on your CPM that might only be
like let's say a couple $100.
And again, you could make
a couple hundred dollars
somewhere else like build your YouTube
go drive Uber or Lyft during you
know for a few hours every day,
make that money and then focus
on growing your YouTube Channel
to build something more significant
and what that thing that's more
significant could be is selling something.
Thinking about can you
create a digital product
we talk a lot about this
one of the reasons why
we started Think Marketing because
the eLearning industry people that
are now wanting to learn online and
the traditional forms of education
are really being flipped upside down,
is gonna be Forbes did an article by 2025
it's gonna be almost a
billion dollar a day industry.
Like 330 or so billion a year.
That means a billion dollars a day people
are gonna be buying eLearning materials.
Yes through eLearning through colleges
and universities but also
through the stuff we create.
We have digital courses
we have all these students
like in our inner circle program that
have digital courses and all
these different people that are
packaging, their
expertise, their knowledge
or just how to do something,
or how to learn something
or packaging, digital communities
these really cool things.
And so that's something you could sell.
But you could also sell
all kinds of things.
I mean, we have a guest
this is eLearning to
but McCann Dogs has a physical brick
and mortar dog training
studio up in Canada.
And they also have an online course
for how to train your dog.
We have other people in our community,
some people that are like
doing kind of cocktail stuff.
And what they do is
they'll sell the shakers
and they'll share the sell this sifters
Kent who just came to our mastermind
in Las Vegas Cowboy Kent.
- Cowboy Kent.
Man, he's got skillets.
- Yeah.
And he's got you know spatulas that
he sells so he does
cooking videos crushing
with AdSense because he's
really grown his channel,
but he's also making money through events.
He's making money through
physical products.
So what the reason we skipped past ads
is you want to think of YouTube,
not actually as your business probably
the worst mindset you could ever have.
It's just a distribution channel, right?
You want to think bigger than YouTube,
use YouTube to make your living.
Don't make YouTube your living.
AdSense can go up and down.
It could disappear tomorrow.
But if you have a real business,
I sell physical products,
I sell skillets and cooking materials and
I have got cooking classes
and cooking retreat.
Well, you've got a real business.
And then if YouTube changes well you
can move to the next platform
like you could go somewhere else.
But so what is that bigger
business you're building?
What is that something
else you're selling?
There's a lot of
opportunities and I'm excited
to talk about that in future
Think Marketing Show episodes.
- Yes, the Think Marketing
Show that was amazing.
So build your influence,
affiliate marketing,
and then sell something.
What incredible tips for having
a small channel and I think again,
even if you have a small channel,
you can start applying these things,
but it is the long game right?
It isn't, you know let's get
to our first 110,000,
100,000 it's the long game
of building something
that's sustainable online.
So thanks for those tips Sean,
thanks for checking out this episode.
We hope you got a ton of value.
And if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the Think Marketing Show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple podcast.
- As we grow this movement of purpose
driven content creators we encourage you
to share it with a friend
and we'll see you in the next episode.
(upbeat music)